i tell everybody about this and it's
true for same-sex couples too if you
similar situation if you are going to
take some time off from work to help
raise
a baby she says if you're going to take
time off
start an llc a little small business
easy to set up
pretty inexpensive really i don't know
what california prices but i think in
new jersey it's like 250 dollars
i think delaware you want to do it in
delaware good point
and she said have a little business so i
would call mine like dana perino
communications
and you have a little bit of
opportunity then to take on a client or
two or a project here and there
but when you go back to the workforce
you will not have a work gap
you will have an entrepreneurial
addition
to the resume so that the chances of you
being knocked back
either from a responsibility standpoint
or salary
is greatly decreased and i thought that
was such good advice i try to mention it
always
so let's let's shift to your book a
little bit because you were talking
about sort of your schedule change and
managing your life and everything else
and when i was reading through this this
morning and i've got it right here
um i i had there's a certain sort of
jordan peterson
feel to this about getting your life in
order but
you know you're obviously aiming this
more towards young women
now you say you say from a former young
woman am i allowed to ask a tv host how
old they are is that a question they're
sure so i love the subtitle it makes me
laugh every time and i also think
it's true like so i'll be 49 this year
so that's like you're still pretty young
kind of because you know this
but you think about people like what do
you learn from
let's say 22 when you start your first
job
to 49 is a lot you know you you go
through a lot and i get asked
by a lot of younger people for advice as
they're trying to climb their way up the
ladder
or try to get their sort of their life
together and i'm
so i wrote the book because all those
young women that come in my office
i could do it all day long i could have
a mentoring business
just sitting here taking calls giving
advice
but i just noticed that they would worry
so much
and they want a specific plan which
specific plans do not exist
um you can have you can put yourself in
the right direction so when i say in the
title
everything will be okay that is true
but you have to do some things to make
it that way
you have to make good good personal
decisions
time management i think that there's a
lot of freedom
in discipline in having some principles
and parameters
in your life that can help you but
there's really ambitious amazing
young people out there and especially
for young women if you're born in
america
first of all you already won life's
great lottery
yeah you're good if you are an educated
american woman
then all you got to decide right now is
how responsible do you want to be and
how hard do you want to work
because you're in the driver's seat and
i don't think a lot of them realize that
you know a lot of them think that um
that the guys are always going to
be promoted over the gals that's not
true that the guys are going to get
the promotions and the raises anymore
that's not true many women are now the
primary breadwinner of their
families and so there's we're in a
little bit of a cultural
shift there and
it is time to step up to be a leader to
be a manager you got to show that you're
able and willing to do it and resilient
the pandemic adds another wrinkle how do
you network
uh in in a pandemic how do you get face
time with the boss
how do you figure out what your next
move is um so i talk about all sorts of
those things in the book
yeah do you think that the pandemic did
anything
broadly speaking to women in a different
way than it did to men so
perhaps being home more homeschooling
whatever you might be cooking all those
things again of course they're not
exclusive
to women but as you know because i
toured with jordan i saw
what so many young men were dealing with
and now
this is more about what young women are
dealing with throw in a pandemic where
everybody's back in the house
and and it's very different yes um some
of the statistics about how many women
have left the workforce
will just blow your mind but there are
less women in the workforce now than
there were some like 30
years ago now they'll come back that
will come back but what do you lose in
that time frame
right because new colleagues come new
technology is introduced we have a new
software system here i don't even know
i don't even understand it um but you
have to get trained on on those things
um you come back to the workforce and
all of a sudden they want to cut your
salary by ten
thousand dollars um because you were at
home now what's happened is
the reason a lot of women have left the
workforce is because kids aren't in
school
so if kids aren't in school it usually
will fall
to the woman the mother to be the one
that stays home to help with the
work from home schedule sit on the zoom
take care of the family and
and women have made a lot of sacrifices
men too men too
um but from the workplace perspective
yes if i could give one piece of advice
that i
talked to that i talked about in the
book a girlfriend of mine
was a global talent officer for a big pr
firm and she has
three boys and she's one of the most
friends that i look at as
how in the world does she do it all one
of those friends
so i asked her about this um issue with
women
this is true regardless of the pandemic
let's say that you're going to have to
take a break from work
whether because of kids work from home
or maybe
you decide that you want to spend
the first few years of your child's life
at home and not at the workplace when
you decide to go back to the workplace
it's almost always true that women will
be looked at as a
difficult hire because they might not be
available you know all the time
work work share is a great idea and some
companies are doing it well the pandemic
has helped
a little bit to make some for some more
flexibility um
but there will be a gap in your resume
right so it'll be like i worked here i
worked here but then there's this gap
and now you're coming back to the
workplace oftentimes what michelle told
me is that
they will be demoted or cut in salary
something like that so she has this
great recommendation i tell everybody
about this and it's true for same-sex
couples too if you
similar situation if you are going to
take some time off from work to help
raise
a baby she says if you're going to take
time off
start an llc a little small business
easy to set up
pretty inexpensive really i don't know
about california prices but i think in
new jersey it's like 250
i think delaware you want to do it in
delaware good point
and she said have a little business so i
would call mine like dana perino
communications
and you have a little bit of
opportunity then to take on a client or
two or a project
here and there but when you go back to
the workforce
you will not have a work gap
you will have an entrepreneurial
addition
to the resume so that the chances of you
being knocked back
either from a responsibility standpoint
or salary
is greatly decreased and i thought that
was such good advice i try to mention it
always
so how much of of what you have in the
book really is just sort of like think
about your life
clearly because it seems to me that a
lot of young people
especially because of what's happened in
the last year not only does the future
just look very murky like the future of
the country the future
of their lives like a career you know
any of that kind of stuff
um but also they're they don't know like
what
what they want in a sense of like young
women maybe they're
they've been trained for too long to put
too much emphasis
on career instead of family same could
go yeah for young men that that the
where they're always being aimed at like
if you if you were a young woman and you
were just like i just want to be the
best
homemaker and wife that i can be and
teach my kids and
and cook and keep a great house that's a
very that's a very lofty thing
my mom raised three kids she did not
work when she was raising us but then
did go back to work afterwards she
worked before and then but had like a
20-year gap on that while she was
raising three kids
to me that was a beautiful thing but
like if you if you say that as a woman
now it's kind of scoffed at by the
mainstream
yes though i think that's changing a
little bit
i do especially as women now have more
choices right so
as i mentioned a lot of women are now
the primary breadwinner so that's
actually
there's all there's a cultural shift
happening there too um
do you have a life partner that is uh
okay with that
you know and supportive and i think that
that is that is
changing just a little bit i have a
piece of advice in there that i call the
whiteboard
incident and it's because of something
that peter did with me
when i was in san diego when we lived in
san diego um
i really wanted to work for george w
bush i wanted to get back to washington
dc where i had worked before
didn't quite know how to do it i was
working in pr
really didn't enjoy it and i couldn't
really see how to get ahead and
we lived in san diego which is where
everybody would love to live except
you're in l.a that's
the other place people want to live it's
san diego sounds pretty sweet these days
so it's
going on in l.a yeah and the mayor of
kevin faulconer did a pretty good job
there during covet and he's uh
he could be your competition if you run
for governor i know i know
so i went to dc i met with a few people
networked um
with folks that i used to work with on
capitol hill at that time it was august
of 19
sorry august of 2001. and then most of
the jobs were filled but they'd keep an
eye out for me and i come home and
i think i really really want to do this
so peter says let's
let's do an experiment it gets the
whiteboard out with this little
erasable marker he says tell me all the
things you want to do in a job
so i listed the things i like to do in
my work
tell me all the things you don't want to
do in a job so i listed all of those
things
and then we assigned a value to those
things
and then it became very clear you added
up
staying in san diego was like a zero
doing anything in dc was like a nine
i'm like oh when you look at it that way
interesting
i also mentored a young woman not too
long ago and she was sort of following
in the footsteps of her family
of medical professionals and
at the end of the chat i said
if if you weren't going to do this what
would you do
she goes oh i am so into
psychology and i bought these books and
i've read all these things
and i've been listening to the podcast
and i was thinking about getting a
master's degree because i'm just so
interested in it but i said well wait
maybe you should be doing that
right right um and so
there's just so much freedom now for
people to be able to do so many
different things
one last story i'll mention um there's a
young woman that i know
who uh graduated in december of 2019
in event management okay she gets a job
she's here in new york she's going to do
events
and she worked she was working for a
company that did events all over the
city big
events like runway type things fashion
week things like that
and what happens in february of the end
of february 2020
no events and the
i think that we are now on our one year
anniversary of our two week lockdown
yep so she lost her job
she also ended up with a skiing injury
like
um so she went home to live with her
parents
and she could have been quite despondent
but she was watching these nurses and
doctors and she knew that
in her area in new jersey they needed
more masks her mother
grandmother was an interior designer who
had retired she had all this extra
fabric
so she had a sewing machine and she's
got a hand so while she was recovering
from her surgery she just made masks
all day long making masks donating them
around but they were super cute
so then people like where can i get one
of those so she started selling the
masks
and then she ended up with so much
business that she hired a couple of
other young women to work for her and
then she bought an embroidery machine
and now she's been doing that and who
knows if she'll ever go back to
event management you know she's she
found a whole new thing and i love the
resilience
and and the spirit and also she was
unconditionally
loved by her family and it's okay to
rely
on your family in times like this
yeah and that's one of the things that's
been so hard for people because in many
cases we're
we're seriously separated yeah from our
family i actually haven't seen my
parents
since this began because they finally
just got the vaccines
and you know they're in their early 70s
so it just wasn't going to happen i'm
finally going to see them in a couple
weeks
but just lose i think losing that
connection because you know
people think it can be replaced by
facetime and zoom and it just can't
no and the other thing that's happened
for a lot of young people when you're on
zoom all the time is um
there's a lot of anxiety about your
appearance
obviously i'm i'm in full hair and
makeup from the show i did earlier from
fox news and so
this is not how i would normally be if i
was working from my office
and i wasn't on tv um
the anxiety about performing
and being on camera all the time you
think of a lot of people
are kind of ex introverts right zoom
gets them way out of their comfort zone
if you have to be on a zoom for three
hours a day with your team
it's been a it's been hard on a lot of
people um
and also presenting in front of that
many people um
instead of just doing it in front of
your team or your board
in in the in the media conference room
and you're doing it in front of
everybody and that anxiety about public
speaking is something that
i also talk about especially because um
one thing that's different from
anything that you and jordan would have
talked about one of the things
one of the pieces of advice i give is
you women
have to find their strong voice so
we have a naturally higher register
um for some especially
on a zoom or on camera or
the voice can be grading
and a lot of young women get into this
habit early on
from their teens and it's kind of
following them into the workplace with i
call it upspeak
yeah talk like this because they're not
really sure about all the things
we just call it valley girl talk
i'm just telling you you will not get
promoted
or chosen to go meet the new client
or go on the big business trip if you
talk like that
and a lot of people dave they don't even
realize that they're doing it
and and if you can gently point out to
them
that they're speaking this way they'll
turn it around immediately
they can turn it off it's like well i do
that i didn't know i do that
and now when they get with their friends
they could fall back into it
but i'm really really big on this
because i see it
i'm like oh she'll she doesn't stop that
she's never
never going to get promoted if you're
looking for more honest and thoughtful
conversations about politics instead of
non-stop yelling check out our politics
playlist
and if you want to watch full interviews
on a variety of topics watch our full
episode playlist
all right over here and to get notified
of all future videos be sure to
subscribe and click the notification
bell